اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذا الموجز يترقبوا
ملايين الامريكيين والعالم محاكمه الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في نيويورك
اليوم شرطه نيويورك تخصصت اكثر من ثلاثين
الف شرطي بلباس رسمي وتسعه عشر الفا اخرين
بلباس مدني لتامين هذه المحاكمه التاريخيه
المحاكمه مشاهدينا يراسها القاضي خوان
ميرشان الذي قرر عدم بث المحاكمه على
الهواء وسمح فقط باخذ صور ثابته لترامب
قبل بدء اجراءات المحاكمه ومشاهدينا هذه
الصور المباشره من منحاه حيث تضع الشرطه
حواجز في المنطقه القريبه من مبنى ترامبور
الذي يقيم فيه الرئيس الامريكي قبل ساعات
من هذه المحاكمه التي ينتظرها العالم
ونشاهد قوات الشرطه التي تطوق هذا المكان
ونذكر مشاهدينا بان الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامب
ستعرض عليه لائحه اتهام تشمل بحسب تسريبات
من وسائل اعلام الامريكيه وبالمحامي ترامب
ايضا او من المدعي العام في منهات بحسب ما
اتهمه الرئيس ترامبا 33
اتهاما اضافه الى التهمه المتعلقه
بالممثله الامريكيه الاباحيه